This collection of materials here: this
is, and it's and it sounds, you know,
horrible, and it is, but this is from our
African American Miscellany Collection.
These are slave bills. So the the file
says 1814 to 1829. So these would have
been people sold or purchased during the
same time period in which David Walker lived.
This one here is from the
state of Louisiana. And it is from the
Parish of St. Landry. And I'll just read
some of it here.
It says, No all men by
these presence that I, John Compton, of
Bayou Boeuf, for and in consideration
of the sum of three thousand two hundred
and fifty dollars cash in hand paid the
receipt where of is hereby acknowledge
have granted bargained and sold, and to
do by these presence grant, bargain, sell,
and believe unto Mr. Joseph LaRose
Fountinot, of the aforesaid parish of St.
Landry County, three Negro boys named
Dick, aged about fourteen years, Dave, aged
about fourteen, and Carter, aged about
thirteen. And for myself my heirs the
little of the said Negroes to the said
Joseph LaRose Fontenot,
and his heirs. And I
warrant and will forever defend as also
against every kind of malady or disease
prescribed by law.
And witnessing whereof
I have here unto set my hand and
seal in presence of John M Debaillon
Notary Public in and for the aforesaid
parish of St. Landry,
this 10th day of June 1818
Then you have the signatures of Compton
Debaillon and Fontenot.
I mean, this is 2018.
This is 200 years ago.  That's crazy. I mean, but it's real.
I'm holding a document here that
represents the purchase, the sale, the
disposition, of three human beings, three
boys. And we have the names: Dick, Dave, and Carter,
ages 13 and 14.
That's absolutely nuts.
And we see that this
was a business transaction. Official seal
is here. There's a notary. This is a
business transaction,
human beings. And this is what David
Walker is talking about the idea that
these people are being treated as
animals, and can you get any lower than
that. 200 years old.